hello and welcome my name is heather
nelson i'm a clinical chemistry fellow
and assistant medical director in
the automated endocrinology lab at arup
laboratories and as well as a clinical
chemistry fellow in the at the
university of utah
lavender chip technology has begun to
revolutionize diagnostics particularly
at the point of care due to its
portability
fast time to result in ease of operation
in this presentation my goal is to
provide you with an introduction to lab
on a chip technology in clinical
diagnostics and particularly in the
clinical chemistry space and although i
will present on chemistry based
platforms much of the technological
principles as well as the advantages and
disadvantages of these lab-on-chip
devices
for medical testing that i'll discuss
will also apply to other fields such as
molecular and infectious disease
so at the end of this presentation
you will be able to explain the
advantages and disadvantages of various
lab on chip technologies for diagnostics
discuss the challenges associated with
standardization and commercialization of
lab on a chip devices as well as by
examples of fda approved lab on chip
based diagnostic devices
to give you an overview of what's to
come i'll start with an introduction
i'll go over the basics what is lab on
the chip
and then i'll discuss some broad stroke
advantages and disadvantages of the
technique
the bulk the presentation will be
discussing different lab on a chip
technology so we'll talk about capillary
flow platforms pressure driven flow
platforms centrifugal microfluidics as
well as digital microfluidics and for
each of these i'll try to provide at
least one example of a current
fda and clio wave device that's being
used clinically
and then i'll finish off with discussing
some remaining challenges and kind of
leave you with a food for thought of
things we need to be thinking about as
we move forward
so what is lab on a chip it's a class of
devices that integrates one or more
laboratory techniques into a single uh
chip
and it's this chip is only millimeters
to a few centimeters in size
and because microfluidics is the core
technology and lab on a chip the term
microfluidics is often used synonymously
with lab on a chip so microfluidics is
the science and technology of systems
that move
external extremely small uh fluid
volumes down to less than pico liters
through micro channels and these micro
channels are on the order of nanometers
to microns
and as you can see as you will see
throughout this presentation lab on a
chip may take many different forms
many will integrate movement of fluid
through channels on a chip via capillary
action or pressure driven systems
some may use centrifugal force to move
fluid through the chip
magnetic particles have been introduced
into some systems
to enhance sensitivity by capturing by
capturing and concentrating the analyte
and that helps increase signal to noise
and then all these platforms need to be
connected to some kind of detector
for readout
and transmission of the signal
a very big interest in the field and in
the research and development arena right
now is using smartphones as a universal
detector because these are very widely
available
and so that's kind of where the fields
going but overall what's summed up in
this figure is that the
the purpose on lab on a chip and
particularly in the point of care is to
be able to develop a device where you
can put sample in and get a result out
without much handling or manipulation
so some of the advantages of lab on a
chip are that it uses very small sample
volumes as well as a very small reagent
volume so you're not going through
consumables as much
it has increased speed to a result so
turnaround times are
rapid on the order of minutes
and then it's easy to operate
the goal is really to automate and
integrate
complex workflows
all within the instrument so there's
less handling of the specimen
also the the small side
side let's lends it to be portable which
is perfect for point of care testing
it's easy to bring in and out of patient
rooms
so that it can be operated at the
bedside
the goal of lab on the chip is also to
develop low cost diagnostics however i
don't think we're quite there yet if we
look at what a cartridge on a point of
care device
costs right now it's still quite a bit
higher than
sending a single sample to the central
laboratory
and a lot of this which i'll get to
during the presentation has to do with
these point of care devices using lab on
chip are multiplex so instead of
ordering one analyte you're getting 10
results
so the goal is to get it low cost some
are there
but certainly not all of them yet
and then lastly the ability to multiplex
is a huge advantage of lab on a chip so
we can analyze many uh different
analytes on one single test strip
uh the most prominent disadvantages of
lab on a chip are that they are much
more prone to clogging because we're
dealing with such small micro channels
and fittings
something as simple as a small fiber or
a piece of dust can clog these narrow
passages
built-in filters can mitigate this risk
and they are implemented into many
devices but it has yet to completely
prevent clogging
another very important parameter that
applies to lab on a chip is that even
small variations in physical quantities
during the microfluidic
experiments can dramatically change the
results so therefore packaging of
quickly controlled reagent volumes and
appropriate reconstitution and mixing
with the sample is very critical to
generate reproducible results
so platforms using larger volumes that
we for example what we use in the
central lab these can
buffers slight reagent volume shifts to
some extent and therefore are often more
reproducible so for example if we
consider
a one microliter loss of reagent when
we're working with a total volume of 10
microliters
this is a percent difference that's
that's pretty significant however when
we're working with a one mil total
volume this is just a 0.1 percent
difference so that kind of gives you an
idea of why microfluidics is so much
more sensitive to volume
shifts lastly the the micro
manufacturing process required to make
lab on a chip is very complex and labor
intensive
and requires expensive equipment and
specialized personnel
this makes scalability and
commercialization quite difficult
however there there has been a recent
breakthrough and expansion of 3d
printing which may help overcome some of
these challenges
particularly in the manufacturing of
plastic microfluidic chips
um so now i'm going to shift to the kind
of the me of the presentation
and i'll talk to you about the different
platforms uh that are used in the
clinical chemistry space
and um coupled with these platforms
you'll see each requires some kind of
detection strategy and most common for
uh clinical chemistry is either
electrochemical or optical detection
um so for electrochemical detection uh
you might have measurement of current
during oxidation or reduction processes
you can measure impedance as a function
of excitation frequency
you can measure potential changes that
are usually translated as voltage
changes
or you can measure current as a function
of potential
for optical measurements that might
include digital or visual color analysis
it could also
include measurement of absorbance at a
particular wavelength
measurement of fluorescence or
luminescence and then also measurement
of a change in refractive index
so
the
the moving into the different platforms
i'll start with the most simple one
capillary flow
lab on a chip assays based on capillary
flow were the first microfluidic
platforms
described and commercialized and as the
name suggests these platforms rely on
capillary flow induced by using
structures with high internal volumes in
small channels that absorb liquids
convenient
and this is achieved by using some kind
of hydrophilic material on the channels
so that it can help draw the liquid
often capillary flow results are read
optically
and some can be qualitatively
interpreted just by a change of color
visible to the naked human eye
but for a quantitative readout optical
detectors can be incorporated into the
platform
usually by some kind of external device
an advantage of this capillary flow is
that it doesn't require pumps
for producing liquid flow so it makes it
especially suitable for low cost
applications
some of the disadvantages of this uh
this
mechanism is that it's difficult to
control the flow since you're just
relying on that capillary action
and consequently you have some
difficulty in mixing up the reagents
one of the
longest used lateral flow based assays
on based on capillary action is the
at-home pregnancy test that many of you
are probably familiar with
this test has been and continues to be
the gold standard for cheap at home
testing
and although we don't think of this as a
microfluidics or lab on a chip because
it does require a larger sample volume
and it doesn't contain these discrete
micro channels
the technology regarding the fluid
motion and interaction with the react
reagent is the same as what we're using
in capillary flow
microfluidics so as this figure
illustrates the sample pad the sample is
applied to the pad and then it moves
laterally through the capillary action
where it first interacts with a
conjugate pad that contains
labeled human chorionic gonadotropin
antibodies as well as labeled control
the analyte in the sample complex with
the antibodies will then continue to
move laterally down the chip
and then it will complex with capture
it'll be immobilized by capture
antibodies
and allows a readout through
optical detection of the color change
um so another concept to recognize and
when we look at this platform is that
it's critical in these lab on ship
devices and point of care testing to
have built-in controls because each
strip represents its own test so it
needs its own controls it's not like you
like in the central lab where we can
control for the instrument in the
morning and then run it throughout the
day
it's it's each one's treated as its own
entity
if we look at something a little bit
more advanced we can discuss one of the
most successful past passive capillary
flow devices the glucometer
this provides a quantitative assessment
of glucose concentration in a drop of
whole blood through integrated sensors
for the electrochemical detection of
glucose
oxidation so as you can see in the
figure enzymes such as glucose oxidase
are immobilized in the test strip
whole blood is then touched to the
sample entry and pulled in by capillary
action
as glucose in the sample is oxidized by
that immobilized enzyme electrons are
freed and collected by the electrodes
which measures current proportional to
glucose concentration
so then if we next look at a more
comprehensive point-of-care device that
uses microfluidics and you can see in
this image the micro channels on the ch
on the cartridge
we can talk about the elire triage this
is a clio wave point of care device
based on capillary microfluidics the
platform has tests for blood in urine
chemistry
for example cardiac markers creatinine
kinase myoglobin and troponin
and it requires just 225 microliters of
whole blood plasma or urine
and so shown here on the right is an
example of that single use test
cartridge
you can see there's a sample entry port
and then capillary force moves the
sample through a filter which helps
separate cells from plasma which
eliminates the need for centrifugation
or complex sample preparation
and then the sample continues into the
reaction chamber where it mixes with
dried reagents and then it's guided
through micro channels that has built-in
controls and structures to ensure
appropriate time and completion of the
reaction
uh overall assay methodology employed on
this cartridge is immunoassay
in which the analyte is binding to
fluorescently tagged antibodies
that are captured on the device for
detection
in order to use these allele triage
cartridges the labs must have the alert
triagiometer pro detection device and
what this is is a portable fluorescent
instrument
it uses a laser light source that hits
the test cartridge that has been
inserted into the meter
and this causes fluorescent dye in the
test device to give off energy
such that the more fluorescence dye
that's given off the stronger the signal
and this provides a readout as to how
much substance is present based on
standards that have been programmed into
the meter
and this alert triage pro can be used in
the laboratory or at the point of care
shifting gears now to the pressure
driven flow platforms these platforms
are arguably the most versatile fluidic
platform especially when ample means of
fluid manipulation are integrated
they may contain mechanical pressure or
pumps to create that fluid flow and then
also include valves that facilitate more
precise control of that movement these
systems are inherently more complex and
they will require integration of both
active and passive components
this can create some challenges with
device handling because it come becomes
more important to try to separate the
more expensive active components from
the passive components which are coming
in contact with sample and must be
disposed of with every run
this figure over here on the right shows
the general scheme of a lab-on-chip
device
for point-of-care applications
with different passive and active
structures which are arranged
such that distinct applications can be
carried out
on the chip at hand
so you can see that it will contain a
means of introducing the sample
in here they're applying the sample
using a syringe and depressing the
syringe applies the pressure needed to
create fluid flow
and then some might uh alternatively
have pumps or motors that do that
uh it will often initially go through
some kind of filter to clean up the
sample and separate out the plasma from
cells
and then it will include some valves
that help control the timing and volume
of reagent mixing
the cartridge will also include dry and
or liquid reagent storage
some kind of means of mixing
maybe even separating and then
incubating the full the fluids as well
as structures for analytical readouts
and waste
the an example of this technology is the
isat istat was one of the first
commercially successful
lab-on-chip-based platforms for human
diagnostics
and it's a single-use cartridge based
system
with all the analytical requirements for
the performance of a test contained
within that single cartridge
so this includes the sample entry well
a fluidic channel a calibrate solution
and reagent which are stored in that
central bladder
it then has some thin film electrodes
which are coated with a specific
ionophore on a silicone chip
and then a waste chamber
this cartridge must be placed on a
portable
istat analyzer which contains a motor to
control the flow of calibrant and sample
within the cartridge
it has an electrical connector to
receive signals from the sensors on the
cartridge and also a electronic system
to measure and monitor the signals
coming from those electrodes
these signals are transformed into
quantitative results based on
established calibrations
and um you can see a very small volume
of samples required and it really varies
depending on the test cartridge but in
general two to three drops of
whole blood is sufficient
this is uh relatively easy to use it
doesn't require any sample pre-treatment
or pre-dilution
and results can be obtained in just two
to fifteen minutes shown in the table on
the right are different cartridges that
are available
listed on the right is the name of the
cartridge and then the left column is
the class of biomarkers that are
included in those cartridges
so if we look at an example of one of
those
cartridges we can look at the ec8 plus
cartridge it has analytes for chemistry
and electrolytes blood gases and
hematology
so you can see various different
electrolytes
the blood gases which is both calculated
and directly measured as well as
hematocrit and hemoglobin for hematology
and so each of these analytes might be
shared in some combination across
different cartridges
another example of a point of care
device that uses microfluidics with
integrated motor control is the epic
blood analysis system
this is again a common single use point
of care device used to measure various
blood gases
and electrolytes in a single chip
so shown in this image is an example of
a test card where you can see it has a
sample entry port
92 microliters of whole blood is applied
and driven into the chip by depressing a
syringe applicator
and there is a sealed calibrator reagent
reservoir which is released following
the insertion of the card into the
reader instrument
via the action of a motorized mechanism
that's located within that instrument
and specifically it's a push pin
in the reader that breaks a valve in the
test card
and drives plungers which causes the
calibration fluid to flow across the
sensor module on the card
the sensor module contains an array of
sensors which contact the
instrument which amplifies digitizes and
converts raw sensor
signals to a transmittable readout
the initial calibration of the card
takes close to three minutes
but after that sample can be applied
and results after applying that sample
can be
read out within about 35 seconds
shown in this image is just what the
epic
reader looks like this is what you need
in order to use any of the epic test
cards and then shown in this table are
an example of some of the different
analytes that can be measured using the
epic system
the third platform i want to discuss is
centrifugal microfluidics
on the the platform the cartridge is
this shape much like a miniature cd-rom
and because of the shape this platform
is also sometimes called lab on a disk
in this system the centrifugal force
generated as the disc is rotationally
accelerated plays a role as a pump so to
speak in generating fluid flow and the
the moving fluid in the micro channels
moves from the inner radius
where the sample is applied to the outer
radius of the disc
and this flow can be modulated by
varying the rotational speed as well as
by integrating valves or different
structures such as congestion
which helps stop the flow unless a
certain acceleration threshold is
surpassed
and so this allows precise uh control of
in movement of fluids throughout the
disc
on these systems readout is mostly
limited to optical detection
because as you can imagine with
something spinning at such a rapid race
and
rate and different speeds it can be
difficult to make mechanical contacts
which might be necessary for something
such as electrochemical detection
so if we look at an example of a
centrifugal
platform we can take a look at the
piccolo
this is a clio wave point of care device
here on the right you can see the
piccolo 8 centimeter reagent disc
and it's composed of three
ultrasonically welded plastic parts
which contain diluent dry reagent beads
as well as on the top a identifying
barcode to identify the spinning
program it will need
the total menu features 31 blood
chemistry tests that range from liver
kidney and metabolic functions
to lipids electrolytes and other
chemistry analytes
these tests are available in 16
different panels where each panel is
contained on its own single disk
a hundred microliters of sample is
located at the center of the disk which
is then inserted into this piccolo
analyzer shown on the right
and then the disc is operated with a
program spinning profile
specific to that disc
and this facilitates plasma separation
mixing with those stored dried reagents
and detection all within about 12
minutes
this platform is
has optical detection
capable of monitoring 28 enzymatic
reactions at nine distinct wavelengths
shown here is just a selection of the
panels available for the piccolo
the analytes included on each panel are
are listed and you can see that some of
those analytes are shared across
different panels
i think this is also an appropriate time
to bring up one of the potential
downsides of these lab on a chip point
of care platform
um so one of our big pushes or
advantages of lab on a chip was to be
able to multiplex
and measure many analyze at once and so
clearly you can see through these
devices that i've shown we were able to
achieve this
but one resulting disadvantage of this
was that oftentimes physicians are
forced to get results of testing for
analytes they didn't want
these multi-analyte panels are pre-built
and are not customizable
so for example if we
look at this table and we say physician
wants ast and alt so they order the
liver panel shown here
well in addition to the ast and alt
they're gonna get total protein totally
total bilirubin amylase so on so forth
um so it may lead to problems as far as
insurance reimbursement how are we going
to pay for these extra tests
um and ultimately causes unnecessary and
excessive testing
and and is a a challenge force by faced
by all these multiplex lab on chip
devices
that we're going to continue to have to
figure out how we want to address
now the last platform i want to discuss
today is digital microfluidics
digital microfluidics is a technique for
manipulation of discrete droplets on a
substrate by electrical control of
surface tension also known as electrical
wetting
so electrical wetting refers as the of
the ability to
of an implied voltage to modulate the
wettability of a surface
so aqueous drops naturally beat up on a
hydrophobic surface
but a voltage applied between the
droplet and an insulated electrode can
cause this droplet to spread on the
surface
furthermore droplets can be moved by
turning the voltage on and off in
succession across adjacent electrodes
this really allows precise fluid control
to discretely dispense
move store mix or even split tiny
droplets within a network of connected
electrodes and this provides an
alternative to the conventional
conventional
paradigm of transporting fluids in
enclosed channels which is what i've
discussed thus far
this technology has actually been used
for quite some time in the sequence
sequencing field and has really
revolutionized and eliminated many
manual steps such as library preparation
quantification and normalization which
has really allowed them to
speed up the timer result for next-gen
sequencing
in addition to the shared advantages of
other microfluidic platforms such as low
sample volumes low reagent volumes
automated processing
speed and portability
this digital microfluidics offers a
couple other advantages
including that it's uh it has no pumps
and valves so it eliminates the need for
active components
additionally clogging is not as much of
a concern in these platforms because
we're not dealing with
small enclosed micro channels
but on the flip side some of the
disadvantages of this technology are
that it has limited interfacing
capabilities with other techniques
and since the droplets are in the nano
to microliter range evaporation can
limit operation particularly in open
plate configurations
and then lastly surface fouling is a
concern
um surface fouling
occurs when there you have an initial
deposition of inorganic valine and on
the membrane surface and subsequent
growth of this fouling layer over time
can adversely influence
membrane or system performance and of
course for putting biological matrixes
in here we there is some concern of
fouling from that
um more recently the application of
visual microfluidics has entered the
clinical diagnostics field with a
platform invented by babies
and in fact babies won the american
association of clinical chemistry
2020 disruptive technology award for
their digital platform seeker
so on this platform an array of surface
electrodes is layered by
another plate to form a chamber in which
droplets are sandwiched and then the
remaining space is filled with an
immiscible fluid
filler and this helps prevent
evaporation that i had mentioned
and then it also helps facilitate the
droplet transport throughout that
sandwich
all the reagents for testing are
self-contained in the cartridge and the
system also allows for
onboard thermal regulation
they developed the platform to be
capable of enzymatic assays amino acids
and nucleic acid testing with integrated
fluorescence and color metric detection
capabilities and so you can just see
from the image on the right some of the
different
capabilities you have you can dispense
reagent or sample you can move it along
the grid
you can merge it with another
sample or reagent mix
as well as split those droplets
uh shown here are the three different
seeker
or three different babies platforms so
we have the seeker platform which is
their first fda authorized platform for
newborn screening
this is initially what they launched a
company for
and what they have approved on this
platform are four different
they measure the activity of four
different lysosomal enzymes from a
single dried blood spot and they can get
answers in less than three hours
the the next system they have is the
finder which is currently under fda 510k
review
for measurement of glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase and then they have many
other analytes on the finder platform
that are in the pipeline
so this is definitely something that's
forthcoming
the finder uses whole blood and just
requires 50 microliters of sample and
can have results in 15 minutes
in addition this company was able to use
their digital microfluidics platform to
develop a sars cov2 real-time pcr
assay and this did receive fda emergency
use authorization where they can take a
nasopharyngeal or nasal swab
in a viral transport media of a total of
100 microliters put it on their chip and
get results in 17 minutes
and then shown here is is just a summary
of a selection of some fda approved
microfluidic based of point-of-care
tests on the market
and i don't show this to go through each
one or even expect you to be able to
read it but rather i just wanted to
illustrate how lab on a chip technology
has really revolutionized and
transformed point-of-care testing over
the last two decades
it allowed us
for the ability to develop these
point-of-care assays by providing the
technology that we needed to really
reduce the size and thereby sample and
reagent volumes reduce testing time
automate and integrate some complex
steps and and
make it into a portable size and be used
in a cleo wave setting
and although this technology has come a
long way there are still many challenges
we'll face as the field has expanded
further
so some of those challenges um
real point of care testing in terms of
simple results sample in results out
requires the integration and automation
of all steps
yet many assays still require extensive
user intervention mainly in terms of
sample preparation
and or reagent addition
as well as just trying to apply the
sample to these cartridges and making
sure there's an appropriate volume so if
there's some way to even integrate that
it would certainly help
scalability is another big challenge for
lab on a chip
this is essential for commercialization
and it continues to
pose very profound challenges for these
complex microfluidic structures
producing mass quantities of highly
standardized chips
has certainly been a bottleneck as i
mentioned earlier hopefully advances in
3d printing technology will start to
close that gap
with respect to plastic microfluidics
another need is to improve the
sensitivity selectivity and stability of
the sensing moduli
because miniaturization tends to
increase the or
tends to decrease the signal to noise
ratio
and so as a result the lab on a chip
provides poorer results than
conventional techniques in the central
laboratory
so there are efforts to explore more
robust recognition elements such as
aptomers
antibody fragments
molecularly imprinted polymers as well
as using techniques such as magnetic
microparticles to help amplify the
signal
which can lead to large improvements in
this area
another consideration is the use of
integrated or universal detectors so
currently um as i showed you all
platforms still require their own unique
detector
and these are pretty expensive and they
may not be available particularly in
resource limited areas
so one area of interest in the research
field still is to use smartphone
technology to serve as a more universal
detector
for accessibility on many different
across many different tests or company
cartridges
of course if we start to use smartphones
there's going to be concerns for hygiene
considerations
including both contamination and
disposal issues so these need to be
definitely considered before smartphones
can be deployed
um in addition many platforms
and development fall off in translation
to the clinic so there is a ton of these
lab on chip devices
in the research shen setting many
looking promising
but the required clinical validation
um the costs associated with that the
access to real clinical samples
um it's a huge hurdle to get these from
the bench to the bedside
so really we might have to consider
implementing some some mechanism by
which we can help translate these
from the research setting into the
clinic
and then finally the the another major
consideration
is development of regulatory policies as
well as social impact of these
lab-on-chip devices particularly in the
setting of moving it closer to the
patient
so questions such as how are these
products going to be regulated how will
be the how will they be controlled and
standardized
what measures will be in place to report
these results and aid interpretation
because results are getting spit out so
much faster there's so much more to go
over
are we going to be sure that whoever's
receiving these results really
understands them
so as as healthcare continues to move
closer to the patient it's also going to
be
crucial to educate these individuals on
the testing um the importance of the
patient preparation do they need to be
fasting do they need to collect in the
morning or at night
as well as the the potential for
inaccuracies due to improper handling of
the testing
they need to really recognize these so
that if there is a false result they it
doesn't cause unnecessary concern or
harm to the patient
and
with that i would just like to conclude
by saying lab on a chip has truly
revolutionized the point of care testing
and it will likely continue to advance
and change laboratory diagnostics as we
know it
it's a very exciting field with lots
more to come
and i thank you for your attention